hello gq i'm austin butler and here are
my essentials
[Music]
guitars have have been very important in
my life um i got my first guitar when i
was 12.
my parents used to ground me by taking
away my guitar
because i i would just sit in my room
and play for
eight hours a day until my fingers bled
this guitar is very special to me
for a couple of reasons
it was a gift from somebody who is one
of my favorite people in this world and
this is the guitar that i albus played
in his 1968 comeback special so it's a
very special guitar in me
[Music]
this is one of my favorite books um i
always try to have a book on me this one
in particular is amazing this is raymond
carver's short stories uh what we talk
about when we talk about love this one's
particularly beautiful because it's uh
it digs into
all those gray areas of life and love
he's able to put things into words that
that we all feel but it's it's really
hard to
um articulate it sometimes
i talked to tom hanks about how to keep
your sanity you know and and how to have
longevity in
your mental health and in your career
and everything he said he said you know
one thing i do is every day i read
even if it's 10 minutes i just read a
little bit of something that has nothing
to do with the job that i'm doing that
sort of gave me this permission from one
of my heroes to
to just have a little bit of
joy reading every day
my next essential is dark chocolate
this is a brand called ritual i found
this in new york for the first time and
i like
i like upwards of 72 dark chocolate i'm
i i'm not a big milk chocolate fan i
respect people who do like it but i'm
just not a fan and now i'll do i'll do
some dark chocolate with some oat milk
and like really cold oat milk and it's
that's a really good combo
all right so my next essential is
a camera ah this is a leica m6 i also
have an m4 that was my first film camera
that i bought
i i was
i was working in new zealand and i knew
i needed
something to keep me sane some hobby
that i could obsess about on my days
that i wasn't working the other fun
thing about this it feels like christmas
morning every time you get film
developed and it's a slower process so
it
makes you appreciate it more and i'm a
lot more decisive about what i'm going
to shoot and
which is different than when you just
take out your phone and take a bunch of
pictures i ended up i ended up buying
this house i had a dark room downstairs
so i had this basement with the dark
room and uh and so i started learning
how to do that and i just spent hours in
there in the red light you know
developing pictures and
i found so much joy doing that
what i used to do was brew yerba mate
tea and then i found this
and
that's kind of this nice cold
afternoon delight lately i just i've
been cracking open one of these and um
and it keeps me going in the afternoon
i guess my thing is i like the mood in a
room to feel a certain way i found this
perfumer in london
and the story that they told me is that
she makes
individual sense for johnny depp
whenever he plays different roles and so
he'll have a specific scent for the role
i don't know if it's true i haven't
corroborated that but i like that story
i had a time where i was doing the
iceman coming to new york i had this oil
that i put on before every every time i
walked out on stage and something about
just
whether whether you're smelling
something or hearing something or
um or feeling something
there's ways that you you just can
trigger a mental state it's almost like
pavlov's dogs you know where you kind of
you can trigger something in yourself
so my next essential is uh
is a good pair of
vintage boots
these i found at a vintage store in new
york
and i just tried them all and
uh
i've got some others that are you know
that this part comes up further but
these are just
so comfortable and then i ended up
watching
uh fight club one day and seeing
tyler durden i'm i believe he's got the
same boots
uh in in uh one of the scenes and he
wears them unleashed and i thought it
made me like him even more
i never know until i try on a boot but
you know some just they feel right when
you put them on
[Music]
all right so what we have here our next
essential
carhartt jacket i've got these in a
number of different colors it's nice to
have it keeps you warm
i just yeah it's such an essential piece
for me i i found my first jacket
i was in my mid-20s and i was in new
york and found a vintage one and had
some at some spot in brooklyn and just
feel good on you know to keep you warm i
like the canvas you know feel to it and
then as they get worn in they just feel
better and better
it's like boots you know and they just
they start to feel like a piece of you i
went through a period of wearing a car
high jacket every day and and uh yeah
even in the summertime i mean people
would think it was ridiculous but i just
it it starts to feel like a security
blanket you know
[Music]
all right my next essential is a good
journal this is a moleskin i have so
many of these i've got bookshelves full
of four of these from over the years
i i use it
trying to work out my own
thought processes whenever i get a new
notebook i end up feeling a lot of
pressure when i when i christen the
first page usually my handwriting is
really beautiful on the first page and
i'll start with a poem or something like
that and then
and then progressively it becomes just a
stream of consciousness actually reading
matthew mcconaughey's book
is he talked about not just writing when
when you're sad not just writing when
you're feeling depressed or anxious but
but also making note of the times when
things are going really well and it's
that way you can look back and say
how what was i doing
at that point in my life that made me
feel
empowered or
grateful or whatever those things are so
i've been trying to employ that a little
bit more
[Music]
so my next essential is
not just water because we can't live
without it but
a good
container to hold it in
i find that if i'm
active
i
am drinking a lot more water
when i go through lazy periods then i'm
not yeah i've been trying to be more
active lately so i've been i've been
really trying to be better about it but
you know some days i
i get to the whole day i realize i've
had three coffees and no water and
that's not good
all right so that's it these are my
essentials thank you gq thank you for
everybody who watched and i hope you
have a good day